o que mais me encanta é no meu trabalho
é de receber essa família que está
nascendo e um desses pais entrou em
contato comigo jorge
o jorge mandou vários e mails me
perguntando como que funcionava ao sair
de recém nascidos como que era como
funcionava as fotos
ele tinha muitas dúvidas e eu ficava
pensando por que esse pai tá perguntando
tanto né normalmente a mãe que me liga e
ali era o pai que ligava em cheio de
questionamentos e muitas dúvidas
aí no dia 26 de agosto de 2015
eu cheguei no meu estúdio como um dia
qualquer
eu estava esperando aquele casal chegar
com a sua filhinha
quando eles chegaram a imaginar minha
surpresa gente sair completamente da
minha rotina eu me deparei com o casal
de deficientes visuais com o casal de
cegos na porta do meu estúdio para fazer
as fotos da sua filha recém nascida na
falha eu peguei a natália e convidei a
análise para ir junto comigo onde eu ia
preparar natália para as fotos eu tiro a
roupinha e um bebezinho fica só com
algumas peças
a crise ficou o tempo todo do meu lado
participando ativamente da vida do
ensaio ea única coisa que ela me pediu
foi para tocar os materiais onde eu ia
colocar natália ela queria sentir a
textura das mantas a textura das
roupinhas que eu ia usar no bebê
então ela pediu para tocar tudo e eu
tive o cuidado também de me adaptando e
narrando pra ela como é que eu estava
fazendo eu vou colocar uma batalha no
público colocado de bruços no colocá la
de mim né
e explicando para ela e narrando pois
aconteceu mas no final eu normalmente
fotografe primeiro bebê e no final faz a
foto da família que é o pai a mãe ea
bebê
eu chamei os dois pra dentro do estúdio
posicionei eles arrumei bem a catálise
quer dizer bem vaidosa ela pediu arrumar
meu cabelo
bem e quando eu coloquei a natália no
colo deles é foi muito emocionante esse
é o jorge a crise ea natália então
imagina a minha moção de fotografar né
está vendo resultado das fotos e não
conseguiu mostrar nada para os pais
no final do ensaio eu fiquei muito
curiosa e eu perguntei para os olhos por
que você quis fazer fotografias da
natália
por que você escolheu a fotografia e ele
falou pra mim que ele não tem nenhum
tipo de sentimento pela fotografia e
nasceu cego ele não sabe o que é uma
fotografia ele nunca viu uma fotografia
não tenho sentimento nem bom nem ruim
porque simplesmente não sabe o que é mas
ele sabe a importância da fotografia na
vida das pessoas pra contar a história
dela e ele quer que a história da filha
dele seja contava desde os primeiros
dias de vida dela eu queria retribuir
pra ele
então eu chamei vai ai vai contar pra
vocês agora como foi o desenvolvimento
do nosso projeto foi o jorge preá caiu
quando a marcha me falou do projeto não
teve como não tinha como dizer não não
era possível na hora eu topei
a idéia toda começou com a necessidade
de dar relevo à fotografia né então o
primeiro passo foi pensar em como
transformar a fotografia que era uma
coisa plana em algum relevo em algum
volume preciso suficiente para ser
percebido com as mãos e daí o marco que
o nosso amigo que a artista plástico
ficou encarregado de cuidar dessa parte
ea gente pensou não vamos entregar uma
foto para esses pais com relevo mas como
eu tinha o respaldo do mar cuidando
dessa parte do projeto a minha cabeça
ficou pior
ano ficou pensando porque só uma foto
porque a natália e receber um álbum com
muitas fotos da sessão e eu comecei a
pensar em como aumentar isso como fazer
essa experiência mais completa e como
também entregar um conjunto de imagens
pra ele
bem eu vou mostrar pra vocês agora como
se deu o processo como as coisas
evoluíram para a gente chegar no
resultado final e aos poucos a decisão
entendendo o primeiro passo então como
eu disse foi desenvolvido pelo marco que
foi o estudo de como chegar nesse volume
e preciso o suficiente para ser
percebido com as mãos
então ali na parte na peça um foi
testado uma gravação a laser sobre
madeira
pegamos o resultado ficamos eufóricos
mas não era preciso suficiente era
bonito para nós mas para quem não
enxergava a gente fechava os olhos nessa
sexta exercício realmente não dava para
identificar o que ele o que era o olho
que era boca então se partiu para uma
outra etapa que foi o teste do laser com
mais potência sobre acrílico e também
não foi possível e na peça três
o resultado final dessa etapa do do
volume que é uma escultura digital feita
com base na fotografia e depois passa
por um processo de impressão 3d que aí
sim a gente ficou feliz com o resultado
porque dava para identificar o que era
cada pedacinho
terminada essa etapa eu pude dar
seqüência que ela ideia de entregar um
conjunto de imagens e não apenas uma
imagem
a página do álbum que era algo fininho
né que era uma impressão gente se
transformar numa caixa alta o suficiente
para receber essa essa impressão em 3d
que era especial assim e ali começou a
se formar o o projeto do nosso álbum
pensando em aumentar essa experiência a
gente teve a idéia de incluir uma áudio
descrição no álbum
então imagina abriu a primeira página
surge uma voz narrando o que tem naquela
fotografia nos mínimos detalhes que a
gente imaginou isso vai ajudar na
percepção além de tocar as peças em 3d
eles vão poder com os detalhes de cor é
da narração formar na mente deles uma
imagem mais completa
então num infelizmente o áudio não foi
possível a gente tentou tentou e por uma
limitação de custos chegamos à conclusão
que não era viável e daí mais uma vez
tínhamos um impasse tínhamos um
obstáculo para a própria passado
foi aí que lembramos do brain e marquei
uma reunião na associação pra falar do
nosso projeto
quando eu entrei na sala da bruna eu me
vi no desafio de explicar um projeto pra
ela que ainda não existia a única coisa
que eu tinha na mão eram os três dessas
impressões 3d e eu tinha que explicar
para ela sem desenhar que é o que eu
costumo fazer para explicar a minha
ideia como eas esse álbum pra gente
encontrar qual a melhor solução de
gravar vídeo de digitais sebrae se a
cena máquina manual sendo impressoras e
ponto a ponto e então foi um exercício
muito de me colocar no lugar dela mesmo
né pra isso e mas enfim conseguimos
fiz todo braille e no final é me deu uma
idéia sim de que era a primeira
oportunidade que eu estava tendo de
testar o nosso projeto de ver se
realmente eficaz porque não me lembro se
eu comentei com vocês
o jorge a camisa e não sabiam de nada a
gente fez tudo como uma surpresa como um
presente para eles então a gente estava
sempre testando as coisas sem saber se
realmente eficaz quando eu lembro na
minha frente eu disse é aí a
oportunidade está aqui a oportunidade
que eu preciso
depois dela ter feito todos o braille
com base na descrição
a gente tinha feito de cada imagem eu
larguei numa mesa as impressões do 3d e
ela conseguiu identificar de qual foto
cada frase se referia
daí foi aquele sinal verde não é mais
assim a dando certo vamos seguir agora
que eu já expliquei todo o processo pra
vocês eu queria mostrar o resultado
final desse processo nem que começou lá
na sessão fotográfica da márcia e agora
está se tomando forma e se tornando um
projeto apenas para com completar a
gente incluiu além do 3d e além do
braille agente incluiu a textura de cada
roupinha que ela usou nas fotos pra dar
aquela sensação da maciez e aquele
cheirinho clássico de bebê também para
trazer aquela memória da que a gente tem
gravado daquele cheirinho de de bené de
corte de livre então apresenta pra vocês
o resultado final que é um álbum
sensorial a gente chamou o projeto de
algum sensorial e ali vocês podem ver
que em cada página é difícil é na
verdade uma caixa aqui uma visão
superior
natália vieira 13 dias uma com o braille
então lá em cima a impressão 3d
a foto impressa a mantinha ea descrição
completa em braile é nós fizemos nós
sentamos e pusemos a narrativa de todas
as fotos de um outro ângulo nota em
aparte do 3d é bem precisa mesmo
então realmente dá pra sentir cada
detalhe e o processo como vocês podem
ver levou nove meses pra ficar pronta
a natália já tava grandona quando a
gente conseguiu entregar
e o que todo mundo me pergunta é como
que foi a reação do jorge da pele
lisinha
como foi essa entrega que é o seu
emprego em eu eu participei da vida
deles é continuar fotografando natália -
a mesa e eu pude ver o crescimento dela
e eu onde eu liguei pra ele e disse eu
tenho uma surpresa para vocês um
presente eu preciso que toda a família
vem até o estúdio e eles chegaram no
estúdio a gente colocou algo em cima de
uma bancada e ficamos eufóricos pra ver
a reação deles é como é que eles vão
reagir já potter 7 a platéia
e aí quando a gente entregou algo nós
dissemos a ele que a gente gostaria que
eles conseguissem sentir todo amor toda
a dedicação e todo o carinho que tinha
sido colocado em cada página do álbum
nino preciso dizer pra vocês neles foram
folhando foram lendo braille foram se
emocionando e análise jorge disse uma
das coisas mais bonitas para nós também
que até que enfim eles iam conseguir a
ver uma foto pelo sentido dele e eles
conseguiram imaginar uma foto e sem ser
pela nação de alguém né
alguém olhar essa foto é assim assim
eles iam conseguir construir a imagem
sozinhas pela descrição do braille e
pelo todos os outros sentidos que a
gente colocou esse algo nos enche de
orgulho nos deixa muito felizes
a gente gostaria de deixar com vocês uma
reflexão que foi uma frase dita pela
camisa e no dia da entrega uma frase é
tem outras formas de enxergar as coisas
na vida
vamos ver com os olhos análise global é
obrigado gente brincava
[Aplausos]